Carl,
there are many kinds of despair.The one
you experienced is
definitely
despair.Those who have darkness in their hearts are attracted
.
There's a deeper darkness than you know
There's one thing I can promise
you Karuizawa Aza I'll protect you from now
on It's much more reliable than Hirata Yamaji
le
If you add a hand to the future
Threaten those who can't learn by saying they'll spread it around Become a
collaborator
I want you to give me the help I need
d Class can't move up as it is now
But with you who can control the girls With you I can
make up for the
lack of unity
moat  North can't do the job
You do it for me I do it
for
you That relationship is enough I
know
But what should I do For
starters I'm
going to win this exam '
Cause you're with me